[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
niedrige siri ihnen allen einen guten
abend für den sport wieder bei mir ist
norbert lehmann ein schwimmender vor mir
ein freitag mit vielen wichtigen
terminen und entscheidungen geht langsam
zu ende und wir werden ihn für sie
sortieren
urteil mit weitreichenden folgen das
oberste gericht in den usa kippt das
landesweite recht auf abtreibung und
macht damit den weg frei für schärfere
gesetze
was tun gegen die globale hungerkrise
die lebensmittelknappheit spüren die
menschen im jemen besonders eine
internationale konferenz will helfen
stressfrei in den urlaub fehlanzeige zum
ferienbeginn in nordrhein westfalen
müssen urlauber am flughafen stundenlang
schlange stehen weil fachkräfte fehlen
wir beginnen mit einem historischen
urteil das weitreichende folgen haben
wird nach fast 50 jahren hebt das
höchste us-gericht der supreme court des
landes weiter recht auf abtreibung
wieder auf es ist ein großer erfolg für
konservative und die religiöse rechte
für frauen rechts aktivistinnen und
liberale ein rabenschwarzer tag us
präsident biden spricht von einem
tragischen fehler das abtreibungsrecht
steht vor einer drastischen verschärfung
die gesellschaft vor einer weiteren
zerreißprobe aus washington an erfasst
hier prallen welten aufeinander in
diesen minuten stehen sich
abtreibungsbefürworter und gegner am
obersten gerichtshof in washington
gegenüber der hat am vormittag das fast
50 jahre alte liberale bundesweite
abtreibungsgesetz gekippt für ihn ist
heute ein freudentag
abtreibung ist ein brutaler prozess der
frauen und kinder verletzt seit 1973
wurden über eine milliarde menschen
getötet das muss gestoppt werden und das
ist der erste schritt
das sehen viele hier ganz anders
der oberste gerichtshof muss untersucht
werden das ist nicht legal untersucht
sie kongress macht euren scheiß job
der oberste gerichtshof mehrheitlich
konservativ besetzt begründet das kippen
des gesetzes folgendermaßen die
verfassung gewährt kein recht auf
abtreibung die befugnis zur regelung des
schwangerschaftsabbruchs wird an das
volk und seine gewählten vertreter
zurückgegeben und die sind bereits tätig
geworden
in 13 bundesstaaten treten ab jetzt
sogenannte trigger los in kraft gesetzte
die abtreibungen verbieten oder deutlich
einschränken ausnahmen für
schwangerschaft meist folge von
vergewaltigung oder inzest gibt es nicht
überall in 13 weiteren bundesstaaten
gibt es noch keine neue regelung es wird
aber von verboten und strengen
restriktionen ausgegangen bundesstaaten
wie new york oder kalifornien dagegen
haben das recht auf abtreibung
festgeschrieben in der begründung
außerdem eine empfehlung nämlich das
überdenken von weiteren urteilen etwa zu
verhütungsmitteln gleichgeschlechtlichen
beziehungen und der homo ehe die
demokraten des repräsentantenhauses
geben sich alarmiert
es hat keinen sinn guten morgen zu sagen
denn das ist keiner heute morgen habe
der radikale oberste gerichtshof die
rechte der amerikaner aus und gefährdet
ihre gesundheit und sicherheit aber der
kongress wird weiter handeln um diesen
extremismus zu überwinden und das
amerikanische volk zu schützen
doch ohne ausreichende mehrheit werden
die demokraten wohl wenig unternehmen
können unterdessen versammeln sich immer
mehr demonstranten vor dem obersten
gerichtshof linke vereinigung drohten
bereits mit einer nacht der hut
benny daniel dass wir uns in washington
vor dem obersten gericht benny wie sind
die reaktionen dort auf dieses urteil
sie sind gemischt wir stehen hier vom
supreme court und hier sind in den
letzten stunden tausende menschen her
geströmt zum einen abtreibungsgegner die
sich natürlich jetzt über das urteil
freuen aber zum anderen und das ist die
überwältigende mehrheit
abtreibungsbefürworter also befürworter
einer liberalen abtreibungsregelung und
die können dieses urteil auch wenn es
inhaltlich ja nicht sonderlich
überraschend kommt immer noch nicht
fassen und machen ihrem ärger luft und
vor wenigen minuten hat sich auch der
us-präsident zu wort gemeldet er hat
gesagt das ist ein dunkler tag für
dieses gericht das ist ein trauriger tag
für dieses land und er werde alles in
seiner macht stehende tun um dem
entgegenzuwirken was bedeutet diese
rechtsprechung jetzt für das land für
die usa
na ja zunächst einmal würde ich sagen
bedeutet es dass der heilungsprozess den
joe biden sicher gewünscht hat der
gesellschaftliche heilungsprozess dass
der jetzt erstmal in noch weitere ferne
gerückt ist das urteil hebt ja ein
anderes urteil von vor knapp 50 jahren
aus dem jahr 1973 auf das wahrlich
historisch war und genau so historisch
ist auch dieses urteil heute nur eben in
die andere richtung also hier hat eine
konservative minderheit sich
durchgesetzt gegen den mehrheitswillen
der amerikanischen bevölkerung und das
wird mit sicherheit dazu führen dass
sich die fronten noch weiter verhärten
dass die pole noch aufgeladen werden und
dieses thema was sie hinter mir sehen
die proteste das wert und wird nur der
anfang sein glaube ich in den nächsten
monaten wird dass amerika mit sicherheit
noch sehr intensiv beschäftigen unter
anderem mit blick auf die zwischenwahlen
im november danke für die einschätzung
nach washington das war benny daniel
live wir gehen zurück hierher nach
deutschland und gewissermaßen bleiben
wir beim thema hier spaltet das
werbeverbot für abtreibungen festgelegt
im paragrafen 219 a in der vergangenheit
führte er sogar dazu dass ärztinnen und
ärzte verurteilt wurden heute aber wurde
diese regelung gegen stimmen aus union
und fdp vom bundestag gekippt das heißt
ungewollt schwangere kommen jetzt
schneller und einfacher an informationen
saar attacke
sie ist vorbestraft weil sie als
allgemeinmedizinerin auf ihrer
internetseite darüber informiert hat
dass sie und wie sie schwangerschafts
abbrüche vornimmt hat christina hebel
gegen den heute abgeschafften paar darf
219 nach strafgesetzbuch verstoßen
denn darin steht unter anderem wer
öffentlich dienste zur vornahme oder
förderung eines schwangerschaftsabbruchs
anbietet wird bestraft
dass wir hoch qualifizierten ärztinnen
und ärzten die solche eingriffe
vornehmen bei kriminal strafe verbieten
dort sachliche informationen
bereitzustellen
das ist absurd dass es aus der zeit
gefallen das ist ungerecht und weshalb
dagegen stimmten heute fdp und union
die streichung von § 209 10 a
ermöglichen hier auch pro aktive werbung
im internet oder auch möglicherweise in
zeitschriften und das suggeriert daneben
dass es um eine ganz normale ärztliche
behandlung geht so sehen es viele auch
die katholische kirche deshalb ist klar
die debatte wird bleiben doch mittag
heute ist der erbitterte streit
politisch entschieden bekämpft und heute
gewonnen hat auch sie christina himmel
kann es noch gar nicht richtig
realisieren und es bedeutet für die
betroffenen dass sie endlich endlich
unseriöse und sachliche informationen
kommen und da steht ihnen schon lange zu
und für christina himmel bedeutet es
außerdem dass sie bald nicht mehr
vorbestraft sein wird denn das neue
gesetz sieht auch vor dass alte
verurteilung nach § 209 10 a aufgehoben
werden
jetzt in die ukraine nach mehr als einem
monat erbitterter kämpfe ums ja wir odon
jetzt hat die ukraine den rückzug ihrer
truppen aus der stadt im osten des
landes angeordnet der für die region
zuständige gouverneur sagte in einem
fernsehinterview
es mache keinen sinn in zerschlagenen
stellungen auszuharren damit
kontrollieren ukrainische truppen im
gebiet lugansk nur noch die benachbarte
stadt musikcharts auch sie steht seit
wochen massiv unter beschuss und droht
eingekesselt zu werden gekämpft wird
aber nicht nur im osten der ukraine
unsere reporterin katrin eigendorf war
mit ihrem team an der front im süden des
landes nahe scirocco unterwegs
wir sind den scirocco der vordersten
front linie in der region treffen die
russische armee ist nur ein paar
kilometer entfernt
andri zeigt mir die stellung die sich
hier seit drei monaten halten in einem
kleinen stück wald zwischen feldern ein
kampf gegen einen technisch weit
überlegenen gegner jetzt hoffen sie auf
moderne waffen die bereits geliefert
wurden
die situation ändert sich komplett wenn
neue waffen zum einsatz kommen dann wird
sich hier sofort die ganze natur des
krieges verändern
andri zeigt uns ein video von ihrem
letzten einsatz das einzige
artilleriegeschütz dass sie hier zur
verfügung haben
es ist uralte technik die die soldaten
hier an der front zur verfügung haben
teilweise noch aus sowjetischen
beständen dass hier aus dem jahr
1984 und sie sagen mit solcher
veralteten technik können sie die russen
nicht bekämpfen deswegen ist es für sie
unglaublich wichtig dass sie waffen aus
dem westen hier geliefert bekommen an
der südlichen front sind raketenwerfer
eingetroffen präzisionswaffen aus den
usa und großbritannien die ihnen
vorteile verschaffen so hoffen sie denn
die russen besitzen zwar deutlich mehr
aber viel ältere waffen
der feind hat probleme mit der präzision
sie machen einfach alles platt wie wir
gerade in der region luhansk und dann
jetzt gesehen wo die hauptkämpfe jetzt
stattfinden sie töten zivilisten
soldaten völlig egal
in der region trabzon an der südlichen
frontlinie hoffen sie jetzt dass sich
der krieg mit diesen waffen zu ihren
gunsten entwickelt
der krieg in der ukraine hat deutlich
gezeigt dass moskau hunger als waffe
einsetzt sagt außenministerin berbalk da
russland die ausfuhr von getreide aus
der ukraine blockiert fehlen
lebensmittel für rund 400 millionen
menschen besonders in afrika und dem
nahen osten auf einer
welternährungskonferenz in berlin hat
gastgeber deutschland mit anderen
staaten und organisationen nach lösungen
gesucht eine soll sein mehr getreide per
schiene oder über alternative wege aus
dem land zu bringen berbalk brief auch
zu stärkerer finanzieller unterstützung
auf es würden über 44 milliarden euro
gebraucht
der ukraine krieg verschärft also die
lage der eh schon sehr armen und von
krieg und katastrophen betroffenen
länder wie beispielsweise im jemen im
nahen osten laut un sind dort millionen
menschen vom hunger bedroht seit jahren
tobt im jemen ein bürgerkrieg über die
not in der hauptstadt sana berichtet
unsere korrespondentin goliath
die hauptstädte husi rebellen die waffen
im land steigen seit zwei monaten eine
mühsam ausgehandelte zerbrechliche
waffenruhe aber die positiven folgen des
friedens werden durch einen anderen
krieg zunichte gemacht den krieg in der
ukraine
er treibt die hohen preise hier noch
höher er macht weizen zur mangelware er
trifft gerade die ersten
wir haben unseren weizen und vieles mehr
von russland und der ukraine bekommen
und jetzt kostet ein sack weizen das
doppelte bei uns
das srb im krankenhaus für unterernährte
der das ganze ausmaß der tragödie im
jemen begreifen will muss in die
krankenhäuser
sie haben so lange gehungert dass ihre
körper keine nahrung mehr behalten
können selbst wenn sie welche bekommen
die hälfte der kinder unter fünf jahren
im land 2,2 millionen sind
fälle schwerer unterernährung hätten
sich hier in den letzten monaten fast
verdoppelt sagte kleber
das un-kinderhilfswerk unterstützte
solche kinder hier aber die
unterstützung heute auf jetzt gibt es
nichts mehr jetzt ist die ganze
behandlung auf kosten der patient
der spenden mangel für den jemen trifft
doch in den zwei jahre alten seit
er ist immer krank es geht ihm einfach
nicht besser ich brauche hilfe von
spendern und ich hoffe sie geben mir
medizin für ihn wir haben nichts
hilfsorganisationen warnen in der
zweiten jahreshälfte wird sich die note
verschärfen und voraussichtlich 19
millionen menschen im jemen hunger
leiden
in brüssel ist der eu gipfel zu ende
gegangen themen des letzten tages waren
unter anderem die hohen energiepreise
und die gasknappheit bundeskanzler
scholz sagte man sei in der eu auf gutem
wege die energiepolitik besser zu
koordinieren
es sei alles unternommen worden um
energie aus anderen ländern als russland
zu importieren jetzt
nach afghanistan dort ist die zahl der
toten nach dem schweren erdbeben auf
mindestens 1100 gestiegen heute kam es
zu einem nachbeben im osten des landes
noch immer werden unter den trümmern
viele opfer vermutet einige abgelegene
dörfer konnten nach un-angaben der immer
noch keine hilfe bekommen
kostenlose corona bürger tests das ist
demnächst vorbei dafür sei die
haushaltslage einfach zu angespannt so
bundesgesundheitsminister lauterbach
heute demnächst heißt es für die meisten
bitte drei euro pro test kostenlos
dagegen bleibt es laut neuer verordnung
ab dem 30 juni für risikogruppen kindern
bis zu fünf jahren frauen zu beginn der
schwangerschaft und für besucher von
kliniken und pflegeheime
seit monaten steckt die linke ziemlich
fest eine partei im dauertief nach
wahlschlappen personalquerelen und
sexismus vorwürfen parteichefin wissler
versuchte ihre mitstreiter beim
bundesparteitag auf einen der anfang
einzuschwören aus erfurt für uns andrea
maurer
es ist der moment in dem die letzten
monate der wahlniederlagen der
machtkämpfe des niedergangs in der
linken kurz vergessen scheinen stehender
applaus für janine wissler über eine
halbe stunde hat die angeschlagene
partei chefin zu ihrer angeschlagenen
partei gesprochen kämpferisch lasst uns
darf sich die miteinander sein lasst uns
aufhören uns in sozialen medien dinge
vorzuwerfen und fehler öffentlich zur
schau zu tragen lasst es nach ihnen
leidenschaftlich diskutieren aber nach
draußen geht das gegen die politischen
gegner für die menschen die auf und
trocken
programmatisch und personell erneuern
will sich die linke hier in er vor zu
viel ist umstritten zu viel ist
ungeklärt das verhältnis zu russland
etwa morgen wird über die
außenpolitischen leitlinien abgestimmt
heute schon ruf der thüringische
ministerpräsident den putin freunden in
seiner partei zu zeig euch im klaren
darüber dass dieser putin kein linker
ist und keiner der für linke bewegung
ist das dass ein autokrat ist und dass
das eine imperialistische artikels mit
spannung erwartet wird die
generaldebatte zu linke me to die heute
noch spät stattfinden soll die partei
hat nach sexismus und
missbrauchsvorwürfen eine aufklärungs
kommission eingesetzt die im
jugendverband der für viele betroffene
spricht reicht das nicht generell ist
nicht wirklich themen und ich habe das
gefühl dass die partei das auch nicht
als thema haben möchte an diesem
parteitag soll das mehr darum gehen soll
mit ja wir machen doch jetzt behandeln
doch jetzt also kann es doch weiter so
geben morgen wird auch die neue
parteispitze gewählt janine wissler
tritt wieder an
nach zwei ziemlich anstrengenden corona
sommern ist die lust auf sonnenschein
und badespaß größer denn je die
vorfreude auf den urlaub die wird
allerdings durch große personal not bei
airlines und flughafenpersonal getrübt
tausende stellen blieben unbesetzt
tausende flüge wurden deswegen schon
gestrichen was das für deutschlands
größtes bundesland nordrhein-westfalen
bedeutet wo heute die sommerferien
beginnen zeigt jan hofer
das erste getränk schon vor dem start so
wollen die airline zum flughafen
düsseldorf ihren passagieren den stress
erträglicher machen stundenlanges
anstehen um die koffer aufzugeben bei
manchen dauert es so lange dass der
flieger am ende ohne sie abhebt so viel
los
zwei stunden angestanden
bisher hieß es man solle zwei stunden
vor abflug dasein jetzt kann es deutlich
länger dauern viele kommen 45 stunden
vorher wir waren heute morgen um halb
acht hier unser flug geht um die großtat
12 wir haben jetzt zwei stunden gewartet
bis war aber auch unser großen koffer
abgeben konnten kläger öfters weil ich
hab den flughafen an dieser vorgesehen
ist die schlange beim check-in zu lang
oder der flug wird abgesagt hat man in
der regel anspruch auf entschädigung und
einen neuen flug zurzeit verpassen viele
menschen ihre flüge aber wegen der
langen schlangen vom sicherheitsbereich
wenn es tatsächlich an der
sicherheitskontrolle liegt das von den
flug verpasst hat dann muss man sich an
den staat wenden denn die
sicherheitsfirmen sind verlängerte arm
des staates damit hat die airline nichts
zu tun das heißt da muss man den
schadensersatzanspruch gegen mit dem
startgeld machen und spätestens dann
wird es kompliziert für reisende mit dem
flieger in den urlaub an vielen
flughäfen in diesem sommer nur etwas für
menschen mit starken nerven
ja und die frage ist jetzt droht jetzt
das reisechaos zdf heute live diskutiert
um 19.30 warum viele stellen offen
bleiben auf unseren social media kanälen
und in der zdf- heute- app dort können
sie außerdem noch einmal genauer
nachlesen welche rechte sie als fluggast
haben falls ihre verbindung gestrichen
wurde
jetzt zum sport neuwert und auch heute
dreht sich wieder alles um dieses multi
sport event die finales in berlin
deutschen meisterschaften in 14
sportarten 190 titel die bis sonntag in
der hauptstadt vergeben werden einen
davon holte heute im kugelstoßen ex
weltmeister david storl und das mitten
in berlin vor dem brandenburger tor
seinen zehnten deutschen meistertitel
sichert sich stoll mit der saison
bestleistung von 20 32 damit bleibt er
aber klar unter der norm für die wm im
juli in den usa simon beyer wird zweiter
vor titelverteidiger dennis lukas die
beide nicht über 20 meter hinausgekommen
titelverteidiger lukas pause hat das
mehrkampffinale der turner vor philipp
herder und glenn trebing gewonnen nach
schwachem beginn verteidigt 1000 yards
weiter am barren seinen titel auch dank
des starken auftritts an seinem
paradegerät
auf der spree hat das kajak tour julia
hacke und jakob shop unter dem bild den
160 meter sprint gewonnen im finale
setzt sich der berliner shop der olympia
silber in tokio holte mit seiner
partnerin aus lünen hauchdünn gegen das
duo pauline paszek und max linke durch
sportgymnastin daria war voller wave ist
zum ersten mal deutsche meisterin im
mehrkampf die 15-jährige sieg vor
titelverteidigerin margarita kolosov war
von wave hatte am wochenende in israel
für die ersten deutschen em medaillen
seit 42 jahren gesorgt
gelungene generalprobe der deutschen
fußball frauen vor der em in england in
zwei wochen das dfb team gewann das
freundschaftsspiel erfolg gegen die
schweiz mit sieben zu null
herausragend klarer bühnen mit drei
treffern unter anderem durch diesen
kunstschuss ein souveräner deutscher
sieg gegen die eidgenossen
zur schwimm em in budapest hat florian
wellbrock mit dem vorlaufsieg auf seiner
paradestrecke ein zeichen gesetzt der
titelverteidiger schlug über die 1500
meter als tagesschnellste an zweiter
wurde der ukrainer im teile romantschuk
mit dem wetter zusammen seit beginn des
ukraine kriegs in magdeburg trainiert
drittschnellster in den vorläufen der
us-amerikaner bobby fing ja morgen abend
an die entscheidungen der 1500 meter
sind wir gespannt vielen dank norbert
leider geht es gewittrig weiter mehr
dazu gleich von christa thoben im
heute-journal interview
landwirtschaftsminister erste mir ab 22
uhr mit marietta slomka morgen begrüßt
sie hier an dieser stelle barbara
hahlweg vom gesamten heute 19 vielen
dank und ein schönes wochenende
[Musik]
genannt ein hoch über dem baltikum hat
bis heute mittag im nordosten noch für
viel sonne und trockene hitze gesorgt
das hat sich aber jetzt geändert denn
dem gegenüber steht dieses tief das
jetzt schon die wolken nach nordosten
verlagert hat und heute nacht verlagern
sich eben auch die gewitter in den osten
aufgepasst heisst es in der ersten
nachthälfte eben noch von den alpen über
die mitte bis nach sachsen die größte
gefahr besteht hier vor starkregen also
lokal vollgelaufene keller und
überflutungen einzel sind auch hagel und
sturmböen mit dabei in der zweiten nacht
ist vor allem noch der osten bayerns und
der süden sachsens betroffen auch im
norden sind immer mal wieder gewittrige
schauer noch unterwegs insgesamt nimmt
die gewitter aktivität von westen her
aber dann deutlich ab die nacht wird
mild mit 10 bis 18 grad noch morgen früh
an oder und neiße morgen haben wir
sommerliche temperaturen zwischen 23 und
30 grad in der altmark und die küste ist
davon wie heute auch mal nicht
ausgenommen dazu haben wir die reste der
gewitter luft die hier noch im osten
hängen mit ein paar schauern und
gewittern vereinzelt ist auch starkregen
noch dabei sonst beruhigt sich das
wetter vor allem im südwesten auch mit
viel sonne von sonntag ab wird es dann
im osten wieder richtig heiß von westen
kündigen sich aber immer wieder schon
neue gewitter an die vor allem am montag
unwetterartig ausfallen tschüss